during covid there were a whole bunch of
studies done individual studies
peer-reviewed that found Ivermectin did
not work the right kept bringing up
meta-analyzes that said actually it does
I said and I said this to Joe Rogan I
reject that show me the actual study I
do not believe this is correct I will
not afford you some benefit to come in
and make the same argument to me if you
do not have a study that is pure bit
incited then I'm not going to entertain
your right opinions so when I bring up
the Cornell University study that's
that's not a study it's a meta-analysis
yeah a 55 peer-reviewed studies whose
conclusion of 52 came to the fact that
there is a less than four percent
detransition rate if you go to R science
Tim you can find out no no no no no no
this come on you're pulling up Reddit
when I'm
berniever last name is pronounced zhen
Degen explains and and downplays why
you're wrong about that 80 to 85 because
she's the one who actually did that
study she's the one who did the study
you cited